hey guys Mary here with a GameSpot news
update would you believe me if I told
you there's a police station somewhere
up in the solar system soaring around
beaming pictures back to earth well as
it turns out that's not too far from the
truth the new horizons space probe which
recently completed a flyby of Pluto and
beamed new images of the planet back to
earth is being guided by the same CPU
which powered the original PlayStation
console as reported by the verge the
probe contains an mi PSR 3000 CPU
repurposed two fire thrusters monitor
sensors and transmit data the same CPU
was used in the original PlayStation
console which was first released in 1994
and ran at 33 point eight six eight
eight megahertz
it was implemented by NASA scientists in
the new horizons space probe which
launched in 2006 and has traveled more
than three billion miles in its journey
according to the verge nASA has always
preferred hardware that has been tried
and tested over newer technology which
could be riskier to use reliability is
prioritized over power which is why a 12
year old CPU was used with a few tweaks
made to help with surviving in space
just imagine what they could do with all
that PlayStation technology if they
explored a real planet sorry Pluto for
the latest news be sure to head to
GameSpot comm
you